fueron 12 en total 12 guardias
nacionales que han sido retirados de sus
prisiones para el evento de inauguración
de mañana entre estos dos entonces
fueron retirados por mensajes y
comentarios inapropiados que el fbi
identificó los otros diez fueron
retirados por cuestionamiento por
comportamiento cuestionable y lo que
está haciendo el fbi precisamente es una
revisión en este momento está pasando
esta revisión de los cerca de 25.000
hombres de la guardia nacional que están
aquí en washington para evitar una
amenaza interna y es que se han venido
rumorando varios medios de comunicación
local han dicho que pues hubo
complicidad por parte de la fuerza
pública durante los ataques del 6 de
enero y por eso se quiere evitar una
incidente más mañana el día de posesión
de yopal de gracias cristal por este
reporte desde la capital de eeuu